and i have to say to the prime minister  he should read the room and it should  see some of the faces on his colleagues  faces he has lost it  mr speaker  we've now reached  the ridiculous scenario  of a prime minister who can't even tell  us where he was  he lives in a world  where he thinks everything is odd to him  and he never pauses to think  what he owes to the public  the prime minister is now a dangerous  distraction at home and a running joke  on the international stage  what does it tell the prime minister and  the public that in the morning that he  has returned from ukraine  the chair of the defense select  committee has submitted a letter of no  confidence in him  prime minister  mr speaker what uh it tells me that he's  more vital than ever for the government  of this country to get on with the job  deliver our kovid recovery plan and that  is what we are doing